foreign
there are many explanations because we
don't have a panel of 10 people that are
not uh represented here and I want to be
fair to give this a little air time so
I'm going to just mention four
explanatory categories at least there
are this much that are not represented
here and I want each of you to give
whatever reactions you have to keep to
them and it needs to be quick so as
noted uh Bernardo mentioned Pan psychism
the idea that you need some sort of a
fundamental aspect of
proto-consciousness and everything and
every particle in the universe it's one
dualism which was a Patricia mentioned
which is of course a historical favor
that the mental and the physical are
both real and distinct there's long out
of favor of course then there's
non-reductive physicalism which has been
gaining favor among some and of course
Julio tanoni's integrated information
Theory so
give me some reactions whatever you
think about these four categories well
there's three quick what's what's the
fourth one what is the fourth one
application dualism non-reductive
physicalism and integrated information
Theory both of those four so uh Pat you
want to take a shot at those
oh well
prepared to believe
things if you
show me
that suggests that what you're claiming
is true I mean part of the problem with
all of these things is that they are
isms for which there are philosophical
arguments but for which there are no
data the pan psychists imply of course
that everything including electrons and
cow pies and Feathers they're all
conscious and and if you ask pan
psychists what the days are they they
say in principle there are no data this
is just a metaphysical position
so when there are no practical
consequences and I don't for example
with regard to bernardo's view I don't
see how adopting that kind of idealism
has any impact on one's practical life
for example if you walk your dog and
your dog evacuates do you pick it up or
do you turn your back and say well you
know
I I can't see it so it's not real
um if it has no impact on your practical
life if there are no data for it then
you're just another person with an
opinion okay
but I don't see that I want to waste my
time
Bernardo your reactions okay they're
enormous implications behind physicalism
idealism and the other isms that
Patricia doesn't want to commit to one
if idealism is correct and we are the
associated processes of a broader field
of subjectivity when you die your course
objectivity still exists this is an
enormous consequence if our bodies are
the images of our own mental processes
including the processes we cannot reach
through introspection through
metacognition then talk therapy is a
much more significant Avenue to
healthcare making sense and integrating
your own mental life can have direct
physical effects like the so-called
placebo effect for which we have no
account today so the consequences are
enormous and there are ways to
distinguish between these things through
experimentation it's obvious until 2012
we thought psychedelics would light up
our brain with brain activity today we
know they do exactly the opposite they
only reduce brain activity that's
something that is relevant or Carlo was
talking about relational quantum
mechanics to which I agree but the
direct implication is that all physical
entities do not have Standalone
existence they do not have absolute
existence so that's a premise of
physicalism that physical entities do
have absolute existence and then
generate mental entities and relational
quantum mechanics contradicts that and
it has been I would claim proven by
experiment for the last couple of years
two major experiments one one by
priority at all and another one about
wigner's a friend a thought experiment
that was done now as an actual
experiment show that raveli was right in
that regard and I would claim this takes
the floor from underneath the feet of
the physicalists okay Carlo your
reaction to some of those other ideas
thank you Bernard I wish you were right
but that there are experiment that
proved relationship with mechanics I
would be very happy of course if they
were but I don't think there are
no I don't think there's a it's a
confirmation of relational current
mechanics
um let me go through the uh your
questions Robert
um uh pan psychism I just don't
understand it because I don't understand
what it means
um in fact uh I I I I listen with
attention was Bernardo says but I don't
understand what it means that everything
is mental because I don't understand
what mental uh means I think the mental
just means related to the complex
feminology uh of things happening in in
Neo in Bernardo uh but you know uh
that's part of uh of nature so uh the
fact that I agree that there is no
boundary between decent rest of nature
but there's no boundary between a
bicycle and the rest of NATO and this
doesn't mean that everything is
bicyclist
uh bicycle is just one of the things
around in nature dualism I don't think
there's many people defending dualism uh
uh today integrated information Theory
Robert you put it as uh as one of the
philosophies maybe
somebody else might take it this way but
I think that's not what they uh it's
it's its value it's one specific
mathematical attempt to capture some
aspect of consequences I would see it as
a scientific theory which presents
itself as a tentative with limits to be
developed is there aspect of it that so
it's part of the game of developing
tools that Patricia is talking about and
with respect to Patricia I would say yes
of course data but Atmos theoretical
physicists you don't do physics only
with that you do physics with data but
then a lot of work theoretical work to
develop good Concepts to make sense of
this data so of course we have this data
we bring them together and we get ways
of thinking
um about uh yeah thank you Carlo I think
to conclude this first part is that
Consciousness does have a spectrum of
radically different explanations I think
we want to leave everyone with that kind
concept that I think we're being
presented here with the perhaps some of
the most common ones but there's a there
is this spectrum and ultimately I guess
only one can be correct our second theme
deals with the hard problem of
Consciousness uh directly and as a as an
arguably unbridgeable Gap that in
principle separates physical events from
mental experiences and Bernardo I want
to ask you you're king of this hill so
would there be any data as uh as Pat has
been offering that conceivably that
could be discovered or experiments
concluded that could falsify your
position as an idealist and convince you
that you are wrong and that Pat is right
if we had absolutely
no instances of circumstances in which
brain activity
decreases tremendously while in our
experience increases in richness in
intensity
then I that one way to construe that as
indications towards something other than
idealism if we had a reason to believe
that all physical entities have absolute
Standalone existence then that would
also indicate that something along
physical lines could be true as it turns
out neither is the case as it turns out
there are a significant and growing
empirical contradictions to physicalism
today and physicalism is reacting
through the traditional epicycles
through all kinds of changes and
additions and torches models to try to
accommodate the anomalies and we know
how that story goes and we know how it
will end Carlo
um
some would use quantum mechanics to
literally generate Consciousness you
said you reject that concept I'd like to
know why famously uh Roger Penrose and
Stu hammeroff with their orchestrated
objective reduction think within cells
that that quantum mechanics is needed in
order to explain uh Consciousness uh um
Murray Gilman famously used the phrase a
Quantum flat doodle to dismiss all sorts
of uses of quantum mechanics that uh for
two other topics that he thought were
were inappropriate I don't dismiss this
attempt at priority I don't think they
are silly totally and and and useless I
think it's good that somebody looks at
that everything is going to Mechanical
right the reason atom stays together is
going to be mechanical interaction with
the molecules mechanics
but I've looked at this specific
proposals uh Roger Pena's others and I'm
I'm not convinced that those works and I
don't see the need of of that uh Quantum
phenomena disappear as soon as is a
sufficient microscopic number of degrees
of freedom heat
um so I don't it seems to me that we're
gonna make sense of what happened in our
mind
um in terms of you know the complexity
of the many things that happen uh we
have a tendency when there are different
uh
strange things to connect them maybe the
stringent of this is connected to
strangers of that sometimes it's worked
but I I don't see indications that
that's the case
I see if I may add one one thing
um a perspect title
let me make this simple uh analogy here
um
what is a sunset a sunset is the sun
going down and disappearing in the you
know plunging of the ocean or
disappearing behind the hill right and
then somebody comes in and says no wait
uh that's all wrong
uh there's a story behind that there's a
physical story behind the center you're
sitting on a spinning Rock and the Sun
that doesn't move at all
um and uh the sunset is just what
happened when you're going when you're
rotating from the lid to the darker part
of the of the rotating Stone on which
you're sitting
have we changed the dramatically
substantially what the sunset is well
we're just giving a better understanding
of the same thing we're talking about
that thing there are different
perspectival description of the same
phenomena at a different level of
complexity and understanding there's no
contradiction whatsoever between the two
so I think when we understand something
this is what's going on we have a
perspective on something okay think how
perspective of this Sunset nothing
happened to the sun
um and we have a better account of what
is going on I think we're going to get
something similar with Consciousness a
better account with what is going on
which makes sense of our perspective
perception of it without any
contradiction between the two that can
AI ever be conscious is virtual
immortality possible in principle in
other words our first person awareness
and personal identity uploaded into
non-biological substrates and and
Lasting for a a long period of time
I don't know I don't think anybody
really
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas